entre la vaccination et les modalités
d'application du couvre-feu pas facile
de s'y retrouver michael techs et
bonsoir bonsoir à vous flore on revient
dans le détail avec vous sur ces mesures
avec et des cas concrets et des
informations pratiques
on s'est d'abord les crèches et
garderies scolaires vont-elles fermé à
18h et bien non l'activité périscolaire
de garderie ainsi que les crèches
peuvent conserver leurs horaires et les
parents peuvent venir chercher leurs
enfants après 18 heures quelle case
cocher sur l'attestation la case numéro
trois c'est à dire déplacement pour
motifs familiaux impérieux pour
assistance aux personnes vulnérables ou
précaires ou pour la garde d'enfants
et si vous sortez du travail vous cochez
d'abord la case numéro 1 liés aux
déplacements professionnels puis la
classe numéro 3 alors pour ce qui
concerne le sport ce qui n'est désormais
plus possible
un entraînement peut-il se terminer à 18
heures alors là c'est pas comme les
crèches les clubs vont devoir réajuster
les horaires de leurs entraînements il
ne faudra pas seulement que les terrains
de foot bmx ou athlétisme soient vides à
18 heures les clubs devront libérer les
joueurs et les encadrants de sorte
qu'ils soient chez eux à 18 heures
nuance
cela va laisser très peu de marge pour
les entraînements des jeunes par
ailleurs les sports en salle sont de
nouveau suspendue à peine un mois
seulement après leur retour
en ce qui concerne les restaurants la
livraison à domicile est elle possible
après 18 heures oui et ça sera le seul
moyen d'ailleurs de se fournir auprès
d'un restaurant le système du cliquet
une collecte est suspendu à partir de
18h ils nouveau sera donc pas possible
de vous rendre auprès d'un restaurateur
pour emporter votre commande
les entreprises cette fois comment
doivent-elles s'organiser par rapport à
ce couvre-feu
alors pour les entreprises recevant du
public la règle eh bien c'est la
fermeture à partir de 18 heures pour les
autres le principe du télétravail
continue d'être la règle dans la mesure
du possible entreprise doit organiser
doit s'organiser pour permettre le
respect du couvre-feu c'est possible par
un aménagement du temps de travail
commencé plus tôt par exemple ou alors
diminuer la pause méridienne
quand ce n'est pas possible pour des
raisons de travail en équipe
d'intervention d'urgence
autre raison l'employeur devra fournir
une attestation pour permettre aux
salariés de circuler pendant le couvre
feu
un mot sur la vaccination qui est
concerné et bien partir de quand ça
débute et comment ça va se passer
alors c'est comment ça commence à partir
de ce lundi pour les plus de 75 ans mais
aussi pour tous ceux qui souffrent d'une
pathologie qui les expose à un très haut
risque face au co vide 19 comme
l'obésité les insuffisances qu'elle soit
cardiaques respiratoires ou encore
rénales chroniques les cancers les
diabètes de type 1 et de toutes ces
personnes peuvent appeler un numéro vert
le 0 800 5,021 400 c'est le numéro qui
s'affiche à l'écran vous allez voir
c'est le second qui s'affiche à l'écran
le premier est quant à lui un numéro
national d'orientation mais surtout
d'information alors est ce que cela
fonctionne
eh bien oui mais le standard du centre
d'appels de teleperformance de fleury
les aubrais dans le loiret était
complètement saturée par des dizaines de
milliers d'appels rien que ce matin on a
testé à chaque fois le même message en
raison d'un trop grand nombre d'appels
nouveau il nous est impossible de donner
suite à votre demande est bon le bassin
blanc persévérer en exactement ceux qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner on
surveillera dans les prochains jours
s'il est possible donc d'appeler ses
numéros et une prendre rendez vous pour
se faire vacciner merci à michael pour
ces précisions